myself in the mirror and accept
that
if you weren't a racist
you condone what a racist did so that's
to me the same thing it's the same thing
so
i agree with you
you got a big following so well god
bless you i appreciate it
hey folks the man with the pinky ring
and the new york thing forget about it
bad breath brookwood and you're watching
another episode of the bad brad birkwood
show on the ringside report web tv
channel now make sure you follow me on
twitter at bad bread
rsr again it's at
bad brad rsr well today folks my special
guest
is the co-host and executive producer of
the very popular the tony michaels
podcast that is now on the midas touch
network he's also a comedian he does
great tick tock videos and he's a
designer we're going to get into all of
that today when we do this 360 interview
so without further ado please welcome
ladies and gentlemen to my show gabe
sanchez forget about it
all right after a few technical
difficulties
and i can't believe that i'm not going
to say the name that i said and it
wasn't jesus the lights came on and
we're gonna talk about that person later
and there's nothing positive but first
of all hey gabe first of all welcome to
the show i greatly appreciate you coming
on pal thank you for having me happy to
be here absolutely
i always start out by telling all my
guests
we know the internet is not always
correct so if i have something in my
notes wrong do not feel shy say brad
it's actually this because i want to be
as factually correct as possible
sounds good we'll start out like this
i always ask since it's the first time
you've come on
in the last two a little over two years
now
personally
how have you dealt with covet the stress
of covid you know family
friends whatever what have you done
yeah so uh
the last two years has kind of you know
i've lived my life you know uh
as cautiously as an isolated you know
while still being social as i can
uh the first year you know
was pretty much like
don't know what's going on you know
limit exposure where mass social
distance things like that my mom's a
nurse so
uh i grew up kind of in and out of the
hospital whether it was there for myself
or just tagging along shadowing her
and you know she was someone who has
been dealing with it she she also got
covet herself in april of 2020
but was also uh you know working in the
hospitals and so she saw it firsthand
and and dealt with it and experienced
that and so you know this wasn't like oh
it's just a hoax or just you know it's
it's
not as bad as the flu it was you know
getting real
stories from her from first-hand
experience so
you know for me it was one of those
things i was like i'm gonna take it
seriously i'm gonna be cautious and you
know i live with a
significant other my girlfriend and so
it's one of those things where it's like
you know i've i've got to live a life
that
makes sure that i'm safe but also that
she's safe and vice versa
so yeah you know it wasn't one of those
like let's just go out party yolo kind
of florida lifestyle it was like let's
you know let's
let's be distant let's do this let's
make sure that we're following the
precautions and take it seriously
because like you know based on some of
the stuff that we had seen and heard or
read or whatever it was you know there's
no joke
okay so
well props to your mom for first night
being a first line responder a lot of
respect for thank you first live
responders especially during the
beginning of this when trump was acting
like well he acted like an [ __ ] all
throughout it right when he was really
insane at the very beginning doing all
the wrong things the first line
responders were heroes so props to your
mother i appreciate her thank you um
you're welcome i look it looks like you
were born and raised in chicago is that
correct yeah yeah so i uh yeah yeah so i
born in chicago uh lived in berwin lived
in oak park uh
you know oak park zidone for frank lloyd
wright ernest hemingway
um there's some other notable figures
who have gone to the high school like
dan castellaneta who's the voice of
homer simpson uh kathy griffin uh many
many other people maybe someday i'll
i'll be one of those people as well
there you go uh yeah
but yeah in and out of the city whether
in the suburbs or downtown you know
that's kind of where i was uh born and
then you know where i spent most of my
time growing up
okay
um i'm assuming you're in your 30s
yeah yeah yeah early 30s early 30s so
when you see the news today i'm not that
far i'm in northwest indiana i'm not
from here i'm from new york but
deb got a job out here at bp in the
morning in indiana at the refinery so
that's what one appear but from what you
see on the news
was it as bad back in your day or has it
gotten worse
in the city of chicago yeah
in your opinion
yeah well i guess it's tough right like
you had uh
you know you had daily right and all the
things that were done whether legally or
illegally uh you know obviously the
south side of chicago isn't as good as
it well
it's still a
politically and in
economically a mess i think um
uh
in ways the city has gotten better you
know through you know i think
gentrification is a double-edged sword
right like you can bring things that are
through prosperity and opportunity but
then also you can you can shove people
away and so you know i as a kid
uh you know many parts of downtown lower
wacker drive used to be a place where a
lot of homeless people would spend now
it's a nice walkable path that you can
go along the river
you know there was caprini green which
was uh uh projects that were
um in the lincoln park area and right as
i was leaving to go to college those
were torn down and because of a you know
the 20 to 30 year cycle of
people move into the city and then they
uh you know have kids they move out to
the suburbs so then that area is
abandoned so then they offer to
different groups of people and then
those people are like empty nesters and
they want to move back into the city so
then they say great we'll tear down
these projects or low-income housing or
whatever and then the cycle continues so
in way i mean i think it has gotten
better but i think in other ways it's
you know there's still a lot to work on
okay and for the younger viewers that
don't know cabrini green was the
projects that were on the show the good
times in 70s
also also in the movie uh uh
hardball with uh keanu reeves okay okay
yeah yeah okay good good factoid there
all right
it looks like you went to college at
marquette and got your degree in
business administration is that correct
that is correct okay talk about that
time in your life
yeah so uh i actually originally went to
u of i my freshman year and then i uh
through a poor experience from a
roommate situation uh just
was like got a bad taste in my mouth i'm
gonna leave
uh went to go visit marquette had a
wonderful time my my girlfriend was
there at the time as well um
and then spent the rest of my sophomore
through senior year in in milwaukee
and now those are the
you know those my my core group of guy
friends are like that's the that's
that's my crew that's my those are my
friends those are the people that i you
know
live and die by
um
so that was a great out that was a a
great time and i i loved every you know
every moment of it
um milwaukee is great because it's also
like a little bit of a mini chicago you
know we've got a river we got downtown
you know
um
it also has even in the time that i've
left milwaukee from school it has
prospered into more developments there's
a ton of stuff you know there were a ton
of factories and
and plants that were shut down but now
have been converted either into
breweries or into lofted spaces or
whatever so like there's bringing new
life you know into the city which is
great to see
but but my time at marquette was was
great i i really enjoyed it i went there
to go study business so i got a degree
in marketing and management information
systems
i uh
got involved with
the paper i was a photographer for them
uh helped you know build the website for
the online newspaper
i just kind of you know did as much as i
could while i was there
okay
it looks like looking at your bio
you work in graphic design is that your
full-time gig or part-time gig yeah so
full-time gig but it's it's not just
graphic it's kind of like
a
a medley i would say of of uh
of design like i'm more of like a
generalist and that way i
do product design mobile design web
packaging you know i've worked
everywhere from
uh
higher ed social
app companies to
crowdfunding companies to uh
financial loan institutions to iot it's
kind of been you know i even started a
company with a few other friends at one
point in san francisco where we were
doing uh premium cannabis subscription
services so we're
before it was
2015 and we were like one of the first
ones uh to start a company called potbox
so if anyone were to look it up
you'd find it okay
all right
let's talk those tick tock videos which
are hilarious
my personal favorites when you do as i
call them cokehead junior donald trump
jr love when you roast him especially
the one where you have the phone he's
calling you like what the [ __ ] you
calling me again for
so what i want to ask you about the tick
tock
it's i i watch him but i don't really
know that much about the platform so if
you would for the viewers kind of
explain as far as what you do so when
you shoot them kind of like the process
editing what goes into it when you're
doing the different characters all in
one and
is there's a time limit on tick tock
videos is it
yeah so it used to be uh 60 seconds was
the math right and then they said well
let's see what happens if we
up that number to three minutes and
then people are able to do longer three
minute videos i think they're they're
definitely more helpful for people who
are doing like tutorials or how-tos you
know don't have they can't get enough uh
in 60 seconds or they need more time
rather
uh and i even saw someone
uh
on tick tock the other day talk about
how there was a 10 minute feature that
they were so it looks like they're it
looks like they're com they're
attempting to compete against uh
platforms like youtube so they started
out with like 15 30 seconds a minute
three minutes and now pushing onto 10 to
see if they can keep you on the platform
longer so okay
and when you put one of your videos
together how long does it take to to do
like when for example when you have uh
different characters like when you're
the press guy and then you're another
guy right you're wearing a different you
know a couple of different ways or
whatever it is
putting that together how long does one
of those take
[Music]
well
you know that's a good question because
i think uh
there are a few elements to it which is
like
i you know i might be on twitter i might
be watching news it might be you know
cruising reading news online and i see
some story
that is just completely
batshit bananas and i'm like how
did this even happen right how did this
come to be and so then
and i think for me because i didn't
start doing tic-tac videos until or like
until the pandemic started and i didn't
start doing like the political
or social commentary on tick-tock videos
until probably
around george floyd that was like when
that really like started to be like all
right i'm gonna start doing different
characters and like different premises
and actually building out what this
story actually played out to be okay uh
the scenario
and so basically what it'll be like uh
i'll read the news see what's going on
i'll start brainstorming i might even
have lines of dialogue in my mind where
i'm like i definitely gotta say that
definitely gotta throw that line out
there to like hint at something that
somebody said
and then i began to fill in the the gaps
as i go and so i'll write it
probably won't take me maybe you know
depending on how committed i am to that
moment in time it could be 30 minutes
could be a couple hours if it's like
breaking away and doing other work and
coming back
and then filming
uh i used to do it outside but now i do
more green screen stuff just because i'm
like it could put me in different worlds
and i'm not i feel i don't feel like i'm
very stuck to be like oh i'm on the
corner on the street somewhere okay
um
so when i'm doing that uh the characters
i figure like okay my characters will
have a suit and have a shirt this one
will have a blonde wig and i'll have the
blouse you know i'll have the bra and
everything you know the whole nine yards
on it uh
uh the only thing i won't do is i just
won't shave you know so people were like
oh do you shave for the female
characters and i'm like no because a lot
of female characters i do i don't really
respect so you know
uh
uh but yeah they're they're always
always the ones that are able to able to
make fun of are always like the
republican you know female people who
are running or whatever so
uh
when i'm
when i'm filming
to also i'm struggling with like sound
outside so i'm like oh the cars are
going by or whatever like i've got to
deal with that
um
so i think in total once i write get all
the costumes film and edit
it's
a handful of hours i'd say you know okay
uh because the other thing too is that
i'll go through and i'll make sure the
captions are there because i once when i
was starting
i didn't really have a lot of an
audience i didn't have a lot of feedback
but then i noticed that people within
the deaf community were like oh
can we get captions on this
and tick tock and other platforms didn't
allow auto captioning so then i would
have to make sure that i would go in and
it's gotten a little bit easier because
now the software i use will
automatically transcribe stuff and i'll
just go and i'll tweet to be like oh
yeah i actually said this word versus
this one
um but yeah it takes probably a handful
of hours if i say from the start to the
finish of it
um
and even when i'm filming i might even
be like oh you know what scratch that i
might
kill a line or improvise something or
change the ending or
riff on some ideas if i'm in the moment
because i might come up with a
completely different idea once i've been
saying the lines over and over again
okay so
the the trump ones which is hilarious
like i said
and junior you get attacked by a lot of
maggots
oh all the time uh i got attacked so
often when i was doing the press guy one
which for anyone anyone listening you
know the the background in the context
of that one is i would be the white
house pr guy and it was me and it was an
intern and we were kind of like the
voice the rational voice
of everyone else being like what the
[ __ ] is going on in this administration
and the the intern was like this naive
kind of guy who like went with the flow
and was like
so
whenever i would do that one especially
if i would use footage of trump like
trump would be giving a speech and i'd
be off to the side and i would you know
chime in with something and do a speech
again chime in like if it was thailand
or it had to do with uh with yosemite or
it was like or like anything like that
where was his actual words i didn't edit
anything i was just cutting myself in to
to speak about it or to correct him
people would come after me i mean i've
got tons of youtube comments where
people are
who tell me to
go back to my country go across the
border
uh jokes on them i was born in this
country
uh you know uh the same people are like
he never said that you know that's fake
news
and i'm like here's the link to the
actual video as you can see i literally
just inserted myself in when he took a
gap in a breath and then he continued
talking so there's a lot of people who
tell me
that i'm wrong that i'm dumb you know
all this stuff and i'm just like if you
don't like how it sounds then
maybe you should take a look in the
mirror because this is the guy that you
support this is the guy that you're
willing to
to get a tattoo and
plaster a decal on your car and put a
big trump flag in your yard like
it also probably spend you know
recurring donations of 50 plus every
month you know so exactly these people
you know will come at you and it's the
cognitive dissonance and it's the
the dunning-kruger effect like it's all
just like it just like became one big
boogie monster
of a
personality
and that's what they are and that's yeah
and i get a ton of hate ton i mean i've
had death threats like
all sorts of stuff that people just they
don't like what they hear and they're
unwilling to accept the fact
even though i'm like
here's a video and here's a link to why
i'm making a video about it so nobody
thinks that i'm just completely making
this up or pulling out of my ass or
whatever right it is in fact real and it
did happen and it's based on this event
you know and so it's like here's a fly
in the wall situation if you don't like
it then again maybe you should take a
look at the party you're in or the
person you support yeah no i agree
looked at some of your acting reels and
saw the commercials you did with honda
um i saw the dramatic clip that you did
that was in spanish so you got a nice
acting reel
um
are you are you sad are you in sag yet
uh no i'm not sad yet i uh
the goal obviously but also you know sag
is a is a double-edged sword because it
is so you know once you're like great
i'm in it and
then you're like okay well here are the
dudes that i've got to pay but also i'm
ineligible for non-union gigs and i
might do the same thing yeah so there's
it's uh it's one of those things where
it's like you wanna
you wanna hold off as long as you can
up until the point you're like
no longer can you you know can you avoid
it and now hopefully you'll you'll be on
more sag projects but yeah it is very
much like a
a good and bad thing at the same time
yeah especially if you're starting out
yeah yeah and it's always been dealt
with when i was on the east coast
okay you want me to join but then i
can't do these other projects and i'm
not getting any projects so now i'm
stuck paying dues for certain news um
right now
how's anything uh popping off with your
acting stuff or is it slowed down or is
it picking up
it has gotten yeah yeah so i obviously
slowed down during covet uh i've done a
few films here and there with uh i just
finished up uh some pickup scenes for a
film that we had started before coven
um and then had to finish obviously once
you know once we were we felt safe and
were able to go back into filming
um
yeah and then also now it's just like
finding the time again to
go out you know auditioning remotely via
zoom and you know sending stuff in which
is always fun because you're like i get
no feedback whatsoever
as opposed to like me in the in the
casting room your dog just gave you [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah yeah that's my that's
probably my dog
um but that is one of the things like
you know uh living in a world of remote
uh auditions now
unless you're actually you know in on a
call with someone whether it's a call
back or what have you that's the only
time you'll get feedback the first time
is like you'll send your stuff in and
you'll be like great here's a you know
maybe how you ask for it and here's an
alt version
and then you're you know
you're at the will of uh if they respond
to you or not but it's just a you know
you get your agent and they're just like
all right here's some new stuff you
gotta be in my tomorrow gotta be my
thursday gotta be on friday
so it's just a it's a game yeah and then
before zoomies you know when i i was
acting 2013 2014 way before covert you
would skype it and you never i mean
honestly i never felt really comfortable
doing it i'd rather do it even if they
say you suck in front of me because like
you said you got that reaction right
there you kind of get an idea where you
stand even if they say we'll call you
back or wait for a callback right but
you don't it's not the same feeling when
you're skyping but you know what i i've
seen
even you know i'm like i said a-list but
i've seen b-list celebrities they're
skyping it because they're complaining
on twitter that they're not getting you
know there's no feedback so it kind of
looks like they're they're pushing in
that direction pre-covert and post
covert right yeah i think a lot of
people are uh
i think as an as a way to be safe
protocols you know because i think
there's a lot of liability and risk
especially as you start production
you're like i don't wanna
i don't want to risk the the health of
other people if we don't need to
especially if this person's not going to
get the role so i would much rather like
safely keep a distance and cycle through
the audition so it's like i totally get
it right and i
you know i you know speaking with my
acting coach and
and audition coach they
are like yeah i wouldn't be surprised if
it sticks around like this it's cheaper
to do it this way it's
more of an efficient process like and
people just feel safer especially since
we're still kind of in this thing so
right
um snl i heard that you tried out for
snl
i did yeah so my writing partner and i
dan we
we went through several
rounds uh last year
uh so last year was
last year was also unique because you
know they were also still dealing with
covid
um
and following their protocol and so when
it came to auditions you know one of the
things that they were focusing on was
like all right well we want to
we want to have more digital content so
we want to figure out people who are
actually making
actual like sketches and producing and
filming stuff uh on a digital side
because you know they they were missing
that
once uh the lonely ion left you know
they missed those digital shorts they
were still doing some music videos here
and there but like
it was the format is just like bunch of
sketches you got cold open bunch of
sketches weekend update you've got a
commercial parody and then you've got a
music video parody that they do and
that's that's it and so they didn't
really have that like here's a digital
sketch anymore
so they were looking for more people
like that
and so we uh we sent in our stuff
they're like great you know typically
how it went was there were three piles
the people who were terrible and we
don't want to see them again the people
who were like
have something similar to what the
current cast has
so they'll stay there maybe and then the
people that we find funny we're going to
keep them and just keep adding to this
cycle at this this pile at the end and
so we you know went through one round
and they're like they love your stuff
uh
then you know a couple months later
um this is probably around april or or
may they were like all right can you
send in a couple more pieces we're like
great you know we'll do something you
know we did one around uh the mars rover
landing
and elon musk all that stuff
uh we did another one just like an ever
green sketch sent those in they're like
we really like them held off you don't
really hear anything for a while you
know much like when you're auditioning
the director decides if you're good or
you're not and whether you hear back or
not so
uh
we did that and then i think we sent in
a couple more pieces of material near
the end of when the decision was made
and
at that point it was just like wait and
see
uh and so we were like we don't know
like they like our stuff but we also
don't know how many other people were
competing against or are going for the
same kind of role
and the way that snl works is like if
they can get you as a duo or a triple or
like a trio of people then it's cheaper
them as a whole than by than essentially
paying for one cast member because that
group is getting paid the same amount as
that one cast member so they're getting
you know three heads or two heads for
the price of one
um
so yeah we went through that auditioned
uh auditioned auditioned and then
finally it was just complete silence and
no one was talking anymore and then uh
you know everyone in the industry was
like surprised in the sense that like
nobody heard anything
until
the announcement came out
uh and then the three new cast members
were added and then also uh you know
please don't destroy uh or do not
destroy where the the digital side that
they got so that was the role that we
were going for
um so you know uh it was an interesting
process you know grateful to be a part
of it we'll probably do it again this
year but yeah it's uh
it's one of those things where you just
like hail mary you don't know
okay
so you're the ep executive producer and
co-host on the tony michaels podcast
so how does a guy
from chicago winds up in uh on the west
coast hook up with tony who's in the
midwest i guess you call missouri to
midwest
assuming that's the midwest or wherever
it's at so how do you tell me the story
how do you guys hook up because first of
all congratulations to getting picked up
on the midas touch network that's a big
deal so congrats thank you love your
show love what you guys are doing
hilarious doing it together
a good combo because he's
he's got his thing you got your thing
and it works together which just doesn't
always sometimes do that when you're
doing it okay whole steal so for the
viewers tell us how did you guys first
hook up
yeah so uh tony reached out on twitter i
think uh we were we might have been in
uh
the same twitter group at the time or he
might have just dm me and said hey
uh i like your stuff i'd love to
interview you
um just kind of shoot the [ __ ] and we'll
talk about satire and parody and comedy
and just whatever you know politics
um
so that was last year it was yeah the
end of last year beginning or the near
the end of last year and so
uh
did an interview had a great time he was
like hey listen
uh if you've got more content you want
to share it you know i can put it on
here
and then basically was like also if
you're in interested if you'd like to
get involved in
helping produce the show because there
might be something happening
uh when she was alluding to the midas
touch thing but like at the time it was
like maybe it's just been like a brief
conversation so i don't know but if you
want to have a platform
like the podcast then you know i'd love
to have you join so
yeah that's and then so then the next
funny enough the next uh
time i was officially on the show as
part of the show it was with midas touch
so it was us interviewing uh brett and
jordy
did that and then now it's you know
it feels like forever ago i have no
sense of time since this pandemic
started so i'm like right i don't know
if it's slowed down or if you're like
quickened up or whatever but like
uh yeah since then it was episode 50 for
um
for the tony michaels podcast and then
it's just been that way ever since and
so we've played with some things here
and there we've added some elements into
the show and changed the format here and
there but like yeah it's a fun one you
know it's just kind of riffing and
shooting the [ __ ] and talking things
political or comedic or whatever but
that's how we uh that's how we linked up
from someone in the midwest to someone
on the west coast okay and i saw your
head on anthony which i saw the show
glad his head he came on you guys had a
good show with him yeah anthony is gold
he don't pull any punches yeah and yeah
i have to say because anthony always
breaks my chops and says brad you know
you
uh you can't curse
on
you know if you do see an internet you
can't i said of course i know i've done
tv before so as soon as you guys got
done i emailed anthony and i said wow
for someone who tells me not the [ __ ]
curse you sure [ __ ] cursed a lot of
american show and he was dying laughing
and he hit me back and said yeah but i
don't curse on twitter well i do curse
on twitter so he got me there but i'm
glad that you had him on and i got a
kick out of the fact that
you know i'm a boxing guy so you know
tony in the back at his right in his
office he's got muhammad ali knocking
out sunny listening to rematch and then
you saw uh anthony in his office that
was probably in sky bridge right that
big picture autographed by muhammad ali
so that was really cool yeah enjoyed
that show
social media i want to ask you two
questions on that yeah
what is off the top of your head your
number one thing that you like you love
about social media and the number one
thing that you freaking hate
uh
i think the thing that i
love most about social media is i think
what
social media was intended for right it
was the intention of of social media
whether it be facebook twitter instagram
whatever was to connect people from
all around the world different walks of
life
and come together on
similar topics right uh or find a place
to have a discussion or like comment or
whatever you know
uh
in an ideal world yeah i've been able to
i've had days where i'm like connect
with great people you know like whether
it's yourself or tony or anyone else in
the comedy scene linking up with them on
the political side
and obviously
the thing that i hate the most
is
how
polarizing
and extreme it can get
you know because there are some days
when you know
i
i think i am a little bit different than
i i have a little bit tougher skin than
most people online
um i don't consider
you know my online personality that's
that's me that's like everything that's
about me right there's different levels
and elements and and and layers to me
um and so when people come after me and
say stuff i'm just like yeah whatever
like i'll brush it off
some things will occasionally get to me
or like whatever
but for the most part you know like the
things i hate the most yeah would
probably be when people
make death threats to me for
for just making a joke right for like
sure yeah i'm making fun of the culture
in but that's not my fault right like
that's it's it's the life you chose and
you know it's not a great one because of
you know baltimore trump uh but
the uh
that would probably be the thing that i
hate the most but yeah the thing i love
the most is the fact that i'm able to
connect with smart funny intelligent
people charismatic and obviously the
downside would be the fact that there
are the opposite of those people who
only live on these online spaces and
social media to [ __ ] drag you down
yeah and and you know sometimes they get
you and sometimes you're like whatever
you couldn't even spell the right you're
so [ __ ] you
i love talking about the right you're i
love when they took [ __ ] marjorie
taylor green's tweet oh yeah that you're
the right you're and then and of course
you know i'm a retired military guy so
when a dumbass said commander and chief
oh my god you're [ __ ] [ __ ] but i was
laughing when you said about death
threats not laughing that you get death
threats but i do like the fact that and
i know you guys that do because we all
[ __ ] went after him when brett called
that little piece of [ __ ] that
threatened his his wife and him oh and
he got him on the phone oh i'm so sorry
oh never do because
i always say this [ __ ] keyboard
warriors you know they like they and
it's no different with the politicians
ted cruz and matt gates and all these
scumbags and that's just what they
wouldn't dare say the [ __ ] that they say
on twitter if you said and i and i've
challenged i said look let's step in the
ring three rounds put up the money
whoever wins it goes to your charity or
my charity but get in the ring i don't
i'm because i know you can't just walk
up and punch him in the face even though
you know i'd love to but you can't kiss
his guests along so let's do it the
right way they're all so [ __ ] tough
on facebook i mean i fought facebook too
yeah especially twitter
but when brett got that guy and called
him they called his dad i was like
that [ __ ] it was hilarious but i was so
glad that he got that little [ __ ]
because 99 of them and just how they are
they make these threats and if you meet
them they wouldn't dare say it to your
face yeah no 100 i get people like that
all the time in my comments or or send
me dms about stuff yeah and you know i
could spend my time you know finding who
you are and you know being like hey good
to see you john you know or whatever it
is
uh and i've done that a couple times and
i'm like is it worth the time and the
effort to do it whatever there is a bit
of like i feel high and mighty now that
i've you know kind of like knocked down
a peg oh yeah so much of those people
will
will say whatever they want however they
want whatever they want you know kind of
uh
to you online it's so easy to hide
behind a keyboard and nine times out of
ten the people that say this
crazy ass vile [ __ ] to you will be a
private profile you'll go there and like
who is this and it'll be like private
right or or it'll be the other hilarious
part is
they will have some sort of scripture
like verse and quote
uh linked in their bio which i'm like
how hypocritical are you to
come at someone and attack them yeah and
then be like well but i'm a man of
christ
yeah it's hypocrisy
but you know the more and more we're out
there on twitter and i know you see it
too it's usually it's on the right but
i'll tell you something we got people on
the left that are [ __ ] nuts
they're like come on your [ __ ] you're
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
right you know because i can't stand i
call it hijacking and tweet
when you have a tweet and it says
something and then they don't want to
address your tweet at all and then they
start with their [ __ ] and the problem
with twitter as you know it'd be one
thing if it was just you know if it was
in a uh
a dm or whatever right but they started
and then everybody piggybacks so your
initial it's like you remember this this
in high school they did a thing years
ago where they had on one side of the
auditorium that everybody sit in seats
and they might say uh gabe
is is
18 years old he lives on west street
pass it down and by the time it gets
passed down to the end it's
joe lives on north street in
uh wisconsin when it was you lived in
chicago right right yeah yeah they do
the same thing on twitter it drives me
[ __ ] nuts i always say look stop
hijacking my tweets and that's on the
left
right yeah i i see you know i
when it comes to politics like so much
you know people are offended or upset by
anything that can be said and whether
it's right or wrong to be to feel the
way you are whatever
but yes very much so i've seen that
before you know because i think twitter
is
well online especially but twitter
twitter so much is like it would be like
you're having a conversation with people
in a room and somebody from the opposite
side of the room comes in he's like i
don't feel that way i don't think that
you know and then they inject themselves
yes like we were in an open room living
room with everyone however i was having
a conversation
with you
and then you know john doe from across
the hall like zips his wine and goes
actually i think this and you're like
well okay no one actually asked you to
come into the conversation but it is
what it is and that's online right
anyone can just interrupt someone's
conversation
and that is a bit of an annoying part i
mean like
sometimes you find people with like oh
that's a good perspective or a good
thing i didn't even think of that but
then there are other other people who
who will intentionally hijack yep a a a
narrative yep and co-opt it for
something else and then you're like well
now it's completely gone and by the time
it goes all the way down somebody is now
attacking you and you're like i never
even said any of those words
you know it's like how would you go back
up the thread and go look at it or go
look at the quote tweet quote quote
tweet of something because i never said
any of what you claim yeah or the
position that i have like i don't know
where you got that idea
but it very much like you said is the
game of telephone you you lose from the
beginning by the time you get to the end
you're like i don't know what the [ __ ]
that was about exactly exactly
politics you said it a couple of times
let's segue into some political stuff i
want to get your opinion on
so i want to read something and then a
couple lines and i want to get your your
take
so on june 16th and i know you know this
already but for the viewers on june 16th
2015 as we both know trump and as i call
her his b best floozy wife came down the
guardy gold elevator for the press
conference and he said and i quote and
this is factual
when mexico sends his people they're not
sending their best they're not sending
you
they're not sending you because you know
he beats themselves twice
they're sending people they have lots of
problems and they're bringing those
problems with us
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime they're rapists and some i assume
are good people i know you remember that
quote because that should have been the
end of his [ __ ] anything that should
have been it everybody's jaws dropped
but it just got worse so the question i
want to ask you having a
being hispanic you said
who now what's what's the break your
family from mexico you said yeah so my
dad's side of the family is from mexico
and then my mom is from chicago okay
what i want to ask you as a hispanic man
when you first heard that and your
circle of people that are hispanic i
just want to stick on respect
what was your first thought and what
were you hearing
from people in the circle when he said
that initial comment
so for me personally and i know my dad
uh you know it was like
who the this like [ __ ] right
here like what the [ __ ] is this like to
openly go out and and make this blanket
accusation
that because what he said there was the
you he's referring to white people
americans
and
he's giving
what is a 99
uh accusation to all mexican or hispanic
people people that are coming from
mexico and then the some of you are good
is like the one percent the people who
work for me you know who cut my lawn and
do my dishes and all this stuff that
he's you know saying only in this
service industry he's saying yeah you're
good you know uh whether you're legal or
uh uh illegal in terms of your your
status
uh but for me
it was
it was a shock because i was like i've
never really heard someone say the quiet
part out loud like he did obviously
using some coded messaging here in there
but for the most part he was you know
pretty racist statement that he made
and i think a lot of people were like no
[ __ ] way like this this is a [ __ ]
joke there's no [ __ ] way that he gets
elected that anyone takes him seriously
that he becomes the face of the
republican party but what he ended up
doing was he ended up letting the
boogeyman out of the closet he made it
okay
to trash someone's wife to trash
someone's
uh uh culture uh
fam you know heritage
what have you like it was okay because
now this guy was running for president
and no one was coming to check him even
though all the people that like quote
unquote checked him during the debates
or during the campaign are now very much
like groveling to be like oh we love you
trump we love you trump you know ted
cruz lindsey graham all of them yeah
so and then when it comes to the people
that were in the close circle
i think there was also some confusion
of like nobody really took him seriously
and i think a lot of people looked at
him as a joke
and didn't really again
even think that it was possible that he
could
be the president because it was so
out
like outlandish like the things that he
had said you know not just on that day
but as he continued through the campaign
each time you know
you realize like oh there's a lot of
white people who feel this way and they
had just been waiting
for the signal like he has a [ __ ] bat
signal up and everyone's like ooh cool
all right great we're on we're like
we're on you know we're gonna do our
thing we're gonna be there to fight
we're gonna be there to to march we're
gonna be there to do whatever
um
i i just like a lot of us didn't really
take it seriously or
we in the event that we did take it
seriously it was like
probably someone who's more streamlined
like maine like this is the guy that's
more of like a candidate is going to get
the nomination and win or whatever uh
but he just continued to just barrel
through all of these people
uh until it became the reality and even
he himself was like
you know i think omarosa even uh in her
book was like nobody on the team
expected him to win so much that when
his name was
uh was was said as the winner no one
could find where he was because he
didn't expect he was going to win so but
he'll lie and say of course yeah right
[ __ ] yeah
so on that same the same talking point
and i asked
uh if i have an african-american guest
on or i have a hispanic guest then i
always ask this question because i just
don't understand it like you said this
[ __ ] guy is a
racist these are many things massages
narcissist traitor liar so many
different things but he's a proven
in his own words racist so
when i've talked to hispanic people on
how there is a lar i don't want to say a
large group i don't know what the exact
number is but there's a larger group of
hispanic
voters voting for him and i always ask
why is that because he the way he talks
he could care less care less about
anybody we don't even care about white
people to be honest yeah but
strictly talking with hispanic people
one of the things that they say and i
want to get your take on this if you
agree or expand on it is
because of the fact that a lot of
hispanic people are catholic and
pro-life
that they say
and we know he's not pro-life we know
that i know he nda the hell out of women
i can't prove it but i believe it and
i've talked to people that that are well
more well in a circle that say yeah but
they they can't 100 proof that he and
the 80s women they had abortions
but
i know they say the pro-life thing
i know when it comes to um
cuban americans the castro thing because
of kennedy and all of that type of thing
in the bay of bigs there's a lot of a
lot of hatred there from all those years
back old old school said i'll never vote
democrat after what happened there right
but
what is your opinion
whether it's older hispanic people or or
younger i don't know if this is more
younger really i don't know what the
breakdown is but
why they stick why they would even like
latinos for trump you know it's like we
know that we know that he pays those the
black people that go to the rallies the
guy with the beard he's got a whole
history if you look him up
he's been arrested he's i think he think
he's a felon but he's definitely been
arrested there's a whole story behind
him he goes all the rallies
but gabe in your opinion why do you
think whether it's older hispanic people
or even if you see young one will ride
or die with trump knowing he's a [ __ ]
racist
yeah so i i think there's a couple
things one the main one of the main ones
is obviously like i've also i come from
a catholic background you know even
though i'm an atheist now but i you know
my family comes deep catholic roots and
so that is one of the things where it's
like you know you you bear that guilt i
still have that catholic guilt to this
day but
it is
very much of like
republican
like the republican party is that you
know conservative christian catholic
like
you know pro-life yes all that is true
and i think when you align that versus
like this progressive like do whatever
you want your body your choice like you
want to get abortion or whatever like
that's your right uh it's very much the
opposite right
and so i think
you know for for many of them it is you
know party is first and it's not the
politician it's the party i don't care
about the other one it's like this is
what the values that i've been raised on
and i've learned and that for the most
part they will support whether extreme
and radical that they might be that
we're approaching this
level of uh
handmaid's tale but
um
it is so much that they yes they they
are attached to
this style this lifestyle this religious
lifestyle that is ingrained within the
republican party so there is that
i also think
that
you find
it
it's a sense of belonging
and
when you look at
the republican party right there
you want it like especially if you live
in like states of texas right or other
places that are uh very heavily
conservative but are a high destination
point for
latinos to come to
florida you know whatever
you
you might feel like you got to look the
part you know and i'm not saying it's
like stockholm syndrome but i do feel
like there is an element of
i want to feel like i belong and i don't
want to bring attention to me right
because
white people already have this idea of
latinos who they are what they do you
know trump said we were rapists and we
were thugs and we were drug dealers and
we were murderers and all this stuff and
you know really you know dog whistles
and all this and really pushing this
idea that we're bad people
and to avoid
being another
person
to add to that to that uh that
stereotype or or to you know
feel like
oh this is another you know bad latino
uh
then then they
i i feel like there's a sense of like i
feel like i got to blend in i got to be
stimulation
right exactly yeah and i can't i can't
really
ruffle any feathers if i got to go
somewhere you know like i got to find a
spot that is safe to go uh but if i stay
here then i you know i know people who
are from texas who are also latino
hispanic and you know i've worked with
them before on different projects or
or
or friends
and they have conservative values you
know when it comes from you know their
family like just shut up work
focus ahead you know like especially if
you're in a town that's all red
like do you need any more attention to
to be on yourself probably not and also
it's like
oh after over time you you know hear the
thing you see you see this thing you you
listen to it you talk about it then you
yourself kind of again like
i you know i call it stockholm syndrome
for this because like
you know you assimilate into this group
and then you're like okay yes i agree
with that that is now even if it goes
against you know
my own people because there is
infighting within the latino community
as well right like that is there i
experienced it when i was growing up you
know in high school you know whether
it's like you're not hispanic enough or
or you're too hispanic or whatever like
you know same groups with other minority
groups as well right especially is how
we compare ourselves to white people
right you know so
i think those are probably the two main
things um there's probably other events
where the you know like you bring up the
you know the the bay pigs uh cuban
missile crisis like we
as the u.s we [ __ ] some [ __ ] up we have
done that over and over again in other
countries in south america where we've
put in some dictator or did this or did
that or whatever
and obviously you know
we do lose a lot of trust
from those places and
that that distrust and that hatred
runs deep in blood and uh i think it's
for you know
you're like oh that was the party that
was in power at the time they're the
enemy yeah and um
i think it's just like a perfect storm
of all this stuff and so when you hear
those terrible things that are said from
any candidate but especially trump you
know some people might be like
uh well he's not talking about me
because i'm not one of the bad oh yeah
right right yeah it's the start you know
it's i always say that
you can have conservative values you
know before i i'm i'm pro-choice if it's
someone's pro-life
okay we could you know right respect
that that's fine that's your opinion we
don't agree we'll have to agree or
disagree but i would say
not this guy though this is the guy that
is none of the things that you think he
is and the thing is he tells you that he
doesn't stop is a million [ __ ] things
but he tells you who he is
and it doesn't matter it doesn't [ __ ]
matter but okay
the other political point i want to talk
on is about
uh the recall that you had in california
last year with newsome and i want to
talk about that piece of [ __ ] he's a
bigot larry elder yep who as you know
was was the republican if he would have
got recalled i believe elder would have
been the one would have been a governor
is that correct okay yep so
elder
went on
the candice owens show another bigot
liar idiot who i can't i can't stand her
can't stand her
and he said on a july 18 2021 show
at prager university
that an argument could be made and this
is quote could be made in favor of
reparations for slave owners whose legal
property was taken from them after the
civil war
excuse me elder however argued
that enslaved individuals were legally
deemed property at the time
he noted that slave owners in their
estates are owed compensation
for the human property they lost
following the end of the civil war and
the passage of the 13th amendment which
partially abolished slavery after 1865.
okay
i'm not going to argue that we we know
that they probably were legally deemed
property which is totally [ __ ] up in
itself yeah okay we know that but the
fact that a black man
would take this and we know it was a dog
whistle we know what it was it was for
the racist like trump does but then he
would do it and candace owen would
[ __ ] co-sign on it
they've sold out their race they they're
just they're despicable human beings
inside and out and i could care less
really what bad [ __ ] happens to them i'm
not saying i'd do anything to them but i
could care less someone said they got
hit by a bus tomorrow i'll be like the
world is a better [ __ ] place because
that's the personification of evil so
what i want to ask you based on that is
new and he got if i remember not exactly
but i think he got like over two million
[ __ ] votes i was like yeah
i know for a fact i know this fact he
got it said 45 of the vote
which is insane and you guys are
considered like the california's
supposed to be like the most liberal
state of them all most most you know
progressive and all these type of things
but he's still got 45 so two questions i
want to ask you all this
newsom hated that much
or the or there really is a like there
is in every other state a contingent of
[ __ ] people that truly define the
word evil racist and everything that
comes with it
so i i think that
you know newsom
he you know he's [ __ ] up along the way
obviously like you know he was a
i was in san francisco when he was
lieutenant governor uh you know he's
mayor before that you know he's governor
now and he's done some great things
right he's you know we he's handled the
covet budget well where we've had a
surplus right he's you know was one of
the states that were offering additional
benefits uh to people who are unemployed
i was one of them i was actually
unemployed in that time because my
company had layoffs because
you know we were we had an arm of
function in china and we had to shut
down operations and we were part of the
group that were let go and i was lucky
enough and grateful and fortunate to
live in california where i was getting
an extra 600 a week which is awesome and
unexpected but totally needed during
covet because
you know we only got a couple thousand
dollars from the government itself
because they were just like ah you guys
will you guys will make it work and it's
like all right go [ __ ] yourself
um
but in the state of california yeah
newsom i think is done is a great job
and i think
you know people have hated newsom from
you know from the point of him being
elected there has always been this like
group that has gone against him you can
say the same against any political party
and who's the candidate who becomes the
nominee and elected official but for
this it was very much like the reason
that the recall got enough signatures
was
in part due to cope with it right like
this was a recall that was started
before this all went down and got an
extension and
got enough of the votes now you know
then you look into like who was
who was the one funding this right
there's that question you know larry
elder who had publicly stated i won't
run for office right on a show and then
all of a sudden within a very short time
he becomes the nominee for the recall
um so he did a complete 180 from what he
previously said um
and
you had you had moments like the french
laundry situation where he
you know went to a dinner with some
friends group of people and wasn't
wearing a mask and of course it gets
documented and that
is used as fuel
to the fire from the other side that
says we got to recall this guy because
look at him you know he's doing this and
he's saying the opposite right like uh
and again wasn't great didn't look great
and obviously was ammunition for them so
there's that
um and i just think that there is a lot
of yeah there's a lot of people who look
at
newsome as just
a person to hate because he is a
democrat or because he is doing
something to hey i'm going to offer
these benefits or try to better my state
people on the other side go uh nope no
no we can't do that uh we can't uh
you know we can't invest money in here
and we can't give money back to the
people and we can't do this like it goes
it's like the antithesis of the
republican party right like they want to
conserve and take it all in for
themselves but not help actually the the
people right we the people
um
and so i think that's what it really is
there is a a lot of hatred for newsome
ju not so much for
the policy has but the fact that he is
gavin newsom and he's a democratic uh
governor
okay
and i have to laugh and you know this i
call her gargoyle i can't stand her you
know what i'm talking about yeah that
was his wife that's his ex-wife that's
what donald trump it is pretty cool
gavin newsom right good looking guy he
got a character to this piece of [ __ ]
done [ __ ] i mean there's really yeah
there's a there's a photo of them
it's a spread i forget what magazine is
from but it's them on the floor on this
rug
like laid out and it's him and then it's
her in front you know and it looks like
something like if you just throw a days
of our lives logo on there that's the
vibe that you would get like it's very
soap
like if you look up like if you were to
google newsome and uh guilfoyle like
laying down
it'll be probably the first search
result
uh
yeah and so there's that and that it was
i think it was maybe a digest or some
sort of profile on on him slash her
uh but they have kids they have kids
together i don't think they had i have
kids okay
uh i think she was she got married again
and she does have a kid
but married to a different guy okay and
then obviously she's with don so i think
there was a guy in between i don't quote
me but i'm pretty sure i mean she does
have a kid right now and i think there
was a guy between the two of them she's
[ __ ] insane she said yes and when she
screams i love sinatra and he sings the
best is yet to come every time she
screams that sinatra's turned over in
his grave because it was a big popular
song and he recorded this yeah in the
60s um one other thing before we segue
into the fun random questions i want to
ask you
is there one stereotype
um and i'm going to say caucasian people
and put them out there a little bit
that they have against hispanic
americans or hispanic people period
whether they're born here or not that is
like the top thing that you would like
to dispel that is absolute [ __ ] and
they use it in the republican party or
even if it's not the republican party
it's just used
um is there one thing that pops in your
head
you you cannot stand it that's just lazy
lazy network yeah that we're lazy
uh i think that is the
the most harmful thing uh that i've
heard growing up is oh
you mexicans or whoever you hispanics or
latinos uh you're lazy
and you know what i find funny about
that is when i hear someone say that you
know they're also the same
same group of people who will also say
that they're stealing jobs yeah so how
can lazy people steal your job right and
on top of that
i
i'm willing to put down money and bet
that the people who say they're stealing
our jobs would never ever be willing to
work a single day in whatever the
industry might be service industry yep
or uh farming agriculture none of those
people who complain about they're still
in our jobs no we're not we are not and
if you really wanted the jobs then you
would march your ass down to the field
and you would go pick out lettuce and
strawberries and things like that you
would go clean the dishes in the back of
the restaurant you would go cook the
food you would go to the hospital
exactly right right if anything i would
look at
when you look at all these jobs i would
say no we are not the laziest people we
might be the most
intelligent and talented people because
if you look at all the industries
whether it's oh yeah so and so is
working on the house like i don't even
know where he learned that but he
[ __ ]
re-roofed the house and he you know
redid the foundation and he was doing
this and do it like
i look at that and growing up
those were the people that i was
surrounded by my dad my family and
others and you know he definitely kept
it within the group of people he knew
and he trusted the most and yeah there
were other hispanic people but also they
were the most talented people for those
jobs and they got it done on time did it
right you know hard workers long hours
like if there was ever a group you know
also you know the black community asian
food as well like hard workers as well
we have to prove ourselves so much more
right um you know in the same reason
that women have to prove themselves even
more in a world of of white men or
caucasian man or what have you yep but
that's probably the most harmful thing
i've ever heard growing up was
oh
mexican people latinos hispanics you're
lazy
and it's the complete opposite from what
you see in the complete opposite from
what then they'll use as another
attacking point to say again they're
lazy but they're also stealing our jobs
it's like we'll pick a lane which is it
you know and i'm gonna tell you when it
comes right to the top of my head and
people don't realize it because he
doesn't go by his real name and he very
rarely says it is [ __ ] ted cruz oh
rafael from canada raphael right but you
don't really see him do too much and
they talk about cuban coffee that holds
a stupid [ __ ] line about the the uh
the judge that's been selected for the
supreme court it's going to go for for
hearings now to make that stupid comment
and that [ __ ] cruise drives me nuts
yeah and what's funny is the only time
i've ever heard ted cruz
display any sort of hispanic background
is when he and marco rubio were on stage
in the republican presidential campaign
in the debates and they were basically
trying to be like who's more latino here
they did a whole like i'll say some
lines in spanish you say some line to
spanish and that was the last we've ever
heard of it yeah up and since then
ted cruz has become this white
overweight wannabe
wolverine like that's what he looks like
right like that's who he is and they're
nothing and that whole party whether
hispanic white or whatever like
there's nothing more than just a bunch
of groveling cowards that have turned
their back from what they
said was the republican party but then
realized once trump got was winning and
got the nomination then they were like
never said that never did that you know
look you said him earlier you mentioned
her name graham he's a xenophobe he's a
homophobic and he's nuts and he'll get
our troops hurt over there with this
this islamic stuff this this muslim this
hatred that he has now he lady g goes
down on him three times a week at
mar-a-lago you know tim scott okay i
don't care that tim scott's republican
he has every right to be republican but
the problem that i have is the
republican party doesn't care about
black people and that no one's going to
tell me differently when this idiot
there's my african-american oh and then
when he says the black people he's the
biggest [ __ ] racist and you said
something earlier and you're absolutely
right i tell my viewers this whole time
he made it comfortable gabe as you said
he didn't start racism in this country
he's been here a long [ __ ] time
that's why it can never be mad and great
because it's never been great for for
hispanic people or black people or for
women of all just and white women too
you know they couldn't vote for [ __ ]
all these years
but
he enabled them where they feel
comfortable to say it on social media
say it out loud
he solely owns that one even though
there was pockets of it but never like
this never like this okay
let's segue into random fun questions
there's no right or wrong answers
whatever top your head is the right
answer
favorite genre of movies
comedy comedy okay
all right favorite comedy movie or one
that you could just watch a lot of uh
uh mrs doubtfire you know is a good one
um
uh the mask i
grew up with that one as a kid jim
carrey is always awesome
i just put up uh
the ringside report song and there the
other day was cuban pete which was
actually desi arness from i love lucy
but he did a skit net in the math cuban
beat if you're oh yeah
yeah it was actually originally uh desi
arnaz okay
do you have a favorite actor that you
wouldn't miss a performance
um
favorite actor
um
i would say
uh leonardo dicaprio probably okay
all right now flip that favorite actress
oh
um
uh let's see
meryl streep probably okay great actual
spectrum okay great actress and i'm
going to stop those the questions for a
second and go back to sun and just
popped in my head i want to ask you
so for the viewers
um
more more on a serious note because you
guys are hilarious what's one thing you
would share with the viewers that they
would be surprised to know about tony
from from the the humanistic side
because what you guys are doing is with
humor and everything else but and we'll
get to this a little bit you you guys
are moving my catch
line and my hashtag in my tagline for
shows moving humanity forward with both
of you do that on your show you take
stances that are always popular and you
get attacked for them and like you said
death threats everything else didn't
come but what's one thing that you want
the viewers to know about tony
outside of the show from the humanistic
side
yeah i think uh for as much as you may
hear tony
uh rant or yell uh on the mic and get
heated um it's because it comes from a
place that he really does care about
this you know um
and i think you know we'll have to show
and
after the episode you know we might be
both heated about something and would be
like this is [ __ ] crazy like what the
[ __ ] is going on
uh
and as soon as the show ends we're able
to just both kind of like
let it kind of fall away and go back to
being normal and i think for tony
the thing that people don't know or may
not know is that he's a very
caring
empathetic person right and so you may
you may catch him when he's on a rant
but you know when the outside of that
you know and you get you get hints here
and there but like for the most part
like tony's a bear you know he's got a
wife's got kids like he's carrying dude
you know he's just like he's a normal
person you know just like you or i
but has a great ability to
to care for for others
okay
and i agree i've talked to him off
offline and i know i know we've talked
about where we come from and our
activism and what he what he experienced
and what he saw and growing up
especially from where he's at in
missouri so he's seen a lot of [ __ ]
uh favorite musical band
oh
um
that's a good one uh
odeza they're a
group um it's like
kind of like lo-fi
like
synth stuff um
yeah i'd probably say that i yeah i've
been finding myself let's i don't know
if it's because like i got into them
when i was in san francisco before that
but i don't know if it's because like a
lot of the days i'm just like well man
this [ __ ] world is nuts and
it does it definitely has more of like a
soothing kind of of sound to it so and i
i'm gonna look them up i haven't heard
of them but the first one i can't in
mind it might not be even remotely close
is are they anything like enigma
uh i i don't know enigma okay uh yeah
but it's like yeah it's like
instrumental are they instrumental
yeah they have lyrics uh as well but uh
it's instrumental you know okay uh
percussion um you know like
different beats okay
okay most memorable concert you've ever
seen
uh
i went to go see uh elton john and billy
joel at uh
um
in chicago at wrigley field
okay
and that was cool because they had
dueling pianos i remember the concert
yep and so it was it was even though i
was like the nosebleeds you know kind of
but it was still amazing because i was
like i don't know i mean i know that the
relationship isn't the best uh right now
i think
but uh at the time
it was an amazing concert and to see
both of them two legends
play piano with each other and riff and
just make beautiful music it was great
okay
favorite solo male singer
um
uh
it might be because of my grandpa but i
whenever we would go visit he would
always play frank sinatra
so whether it was christmas music or
whatever like even like one of the
things that is a
a few it was
i think five years ago at this time when
he passed away it was like the thing
that my mom you know went out and had
her you know reception and her dinner
and she was just blasting frank the
whole time you know and she was like
this is what he would want this is you
know exactly what he want to listen to
so okay those are the things that i grew
up with and frank came to chicago he
played chicago a lot and then back in
the 60s big time with sam g khan was a
gangster there but uh he came to chicago
uh united center so united center is
that what's called
yeah united center is the it's on yeah
madison
madison where uh the bulls play and the
blackhawks yeah okay now flip that do
you have a favorite female singer
oh
um
maybe adele
you know sometimes you know rolling in
the deep yep great great song yeah love
her okay do you have a favorite
noise or sound
you'd like to hear
ooh
uh
you do you know what the uh like the rap
air horn is where it's like
for some reason i
find that
it will it will never not make me laugh
so much that i have an app on my phone
that just just plays that sound
okay
now flip it
least
favorite noise or sound
uh
uh
nails on a chalkboard you know that and
any that like i don't know like
there are cert probably certain more
than that but they're probably you know
certain sounds that they
it's uh
sends
like a ripple chill through and you're
like yeah i don't feel right right now
but well it's funny funny you mentioned
nails on chalkboard i don't know if you
remember this but debbie and i watched
jaws last night she never saw the whole
movie oh yeah if you aren't it i don't
know if you remember when he's in the
they're in the uh the room and they're
talking about catching the shark and
they're offering three thousand dollars
all of a sudden your nails on a
chalkboard and it's the captain of the
boat that you know goes out robert
shaw's the actor and he draws his
drawing
in chalk with his nails jaws and hearing
it all these years later i saw when i
was seven it's the same thing i can't
stand that's one of my my worst ones too
but also an impressive movie where the
soundtrack you know the theme song is
yeah
like it
it it's
to this day
you you know i don't know i guess for
younger people who haven't seen it but
it's iconic where you hear it and you
know immediately right like there are
certain soundtracks over here but that
is one where it's literally like
nothing more than that you know and you
know something else coming yep yeah and
i was funny because i was telling them i
said look at what they did i said 1975.
you didn't see the shark for about 30-40
minutes but you heard that music
that one other movies that's iconic like
that you know some shit's going down is
the godfather when you hear the music of
the godfather you know someone's going
to get whacked like the horse is hidden
a bit you heard the same thing and it's
always something like that
okay do you have
a favorite food
uh
tacos
okay from where
uh
homemade or from a restaurant
from a restaurant i would say like i'll
probably i mean
i don't think
my my dad's will ever be beaten you know
but uh because he's he's from works in
the restaurant industry so i grew up
with uh with food all the time
but
uh a next close favor would be
uh well i guess homemade so it would be
my ability so
she her cooking
uh
in mexico is always great but other than
that i'm always on the search for new
spots in la uh
uh there's one that's not too far from
me it's called el zarape which is pretty
good
uh there's a spot called uh it's angels
in um
off
near york
in highland park
that's got some amazing
uh alpaca store um
there's this yeah it's there's there's a
few spots i went to i was actually
recently in mexico as a family with my
girlfriend
and we went to a few spots that the
alpha store tacos were
so good and so that's i don't know it
may sound cliche to be like oh you know
he's mexican he likes tacos but there's
something about him oh no i love tacos
too dude i'm telling you and not taco
[ __ ] belle that's the worst [ __ ] i'm
telling we got one around the corner
but i love homemade tacos okay
what is the first
job you ever had
uh first job was walking dogs
okay in chicago
yeah yeah so there was a buddy of mine
uh he had moved away and
i
hung out with him all the time at his
place and his next-door neighbor had a
dog
uh and they were looking for a new
person to walk their dog so like hey
would you be interested cool and then
funny enough the people that moved into
his house
also had two dogs so they're like oh
well he's walking their dog would you
also be willing to walk our dog so then
i
that's you know easy money you know
after school go there walk the dogs pick
up the poop the whole jazz play with
them and then put them away and then go
back home or go to whatever practice i
had for sports okay
if you would hit the lottery tomorrow
for 200 300 400 million dollars
what's the first thing you would do
uh i would pay off all of my family's
debts
anything that they had my brother any of
my brothers school stuff my mom's school
stuff or housing or
uh my dad you know giving money to open
up additional restaurants or whatever um
that would probably be the first thing
that i would just easy easy done sign
check done
okay
do you have any hobbies
uh yeah so
uh i got into when i lived in san
francisco i
got into uh
like furniture making randomly so
you know is
uh i sketch out a design for something
and then i would make a piece of
furniture like we've got a coffee table
that is made out of like uh
metal
uh
hairpin legs with wooden board
uh i made a
a desk that's actually out in the
kitchen
i'm using
a butcher block sand down re-coat and
then use uh pipe actually uh like
plumbing pipe three quarter inch you
know inch pipe
um i built a a bar cart shelves
uh a dresser like
but it was also during a time when
i i think i had more time but i needed
something a new thing to challenge so
i'll just learn how to do it and then it
was just like me at the lumber yard or
me at the hardware store and i would
just like kind of figure out how to do
it
um
and that would be probably the one of
the main hobbies that i have um okay
outside of you know doing comedy on the
side okay
if you could meet one person
from any time in history
dead or alive in any walk of life
who would it be
and what would be your either your first
question
or a couple talking points
for this person
um
so the first one that comes to mind
would be
as a kid
i had to do a history fair and the
person that i did was abraham lincoln
okay uh and so it was honest abe or for
me my character was on escape right
and so i had a big big hat on and stuff
um but also
later on in life
uh it was seventh or eighth grade we
took a trip down to springfield so we're
able to actually visit the capitol and
uh
check out all the chambers and go see
where abraham lincoln was you know
raised and kind of life he lived
and
i look at that as someone who you know
whether the republican party wants to
take that claim of where the party
lincoln
whatever uh i look at him as someone
who
was there at a defining moment obviously
in our country's history right
um
in the way that he saw the potential you
know you've got the amounts of face
proclamation you've got all these things
in which
uh the country was really
well
moving into its own and to beco trying
to be better and i look at him
and i the one of the first things i
probably ask is like what you know
assuming
he could have a a plan right if he was
like hey what's a 10-point plan going
forward where you'd like to see things
go i would want to know kind of like
you were taken early on
and i would be curious to know kind of
what your plan was
right because i'm sure he was you know
it wasn't just one and done to get this
and like we're like the country saved
you know
it was one of these like
there are probably other
other achievements or other actions or
policies that he'd want to go about
doing and so i
that would be one of the things where
i'm like just you know
inundate me with what that plan would be
you know tell me what that plan is and
also like
you know
and uh
and vice versa like looking at where we
are right now
like is you know
can you give me
some perspective i'm like how the [ __ ]
do we get out of this [ __ ] you know like
i know that's what and i know talking
about lincoln he had to drive you nuts
when trump tries to compare himself to
lincoln are you [ __ ] kidding me
yeah anytime i hear the republican party
say we're the party lincoln and i'm like
did you guys not forget how the party
had changed flip-flopped and done this
and done that like you aren't the
republican party isn't what you guys
think it was or is you have the same
name yeah but it doesn't mean that
you're actually the same group of people
with the same founding principles in the
same moral yeah like clause so
yeah
lincoln wouldn't accept
i tell people this all the time they
could hate the republican party but i
honestly believe that
you talk about lincoln of course lincoln
but you know papa bush reagan all of
them with all of their mistakes
to me and people could debate if they
want they would have never allowed
openly a green a bobart gates crew all
this crazy [ __ ] i don't i just don't
believe it i think they would there was
oh hell no i mean
yeah you look at the same thing that's
happening right now with ukraine and
russia and you got all these you know
republicans who are like
let's go let's go vladi daddy and then
you know then it's like did you ignore
what happened in the 80s with reagan
like he literally this doesn't make any
sense you guys contradict yourself every
single [ __ ] day with something you
either said previously or
what your the party of lincoln and the
party reagan and you know
you guys don't
you guys go with the wind you know like
in uh
in chicago you know we're called the
windy city not because of it's windy
but because of politicians right the
blow whichever way the wind goes cook
county crook county right right exactly
yeah and so you
you look at that it's like you guys are
no different than the politicians who
would say one thing and do the other
like
you know at least
pick a lane and go forward and if [ __ ]
it gets hard then say you know what i
was wrong but don't one week say this
and the next week say the other i wanna
you know what i'm gonna have to correct
you on that one it's not even a weak
game it's a [ __ ] hour later i know
it's not it really is normally it was a
week later you know it's like news
cycles you notice you're in the media
business news cycles used to be 24 48
hours trump came along it's not even 48
[ __ ] minutes right they can't keep up
with it when he was president the next
[ __ ] because he said so much
okay
if you could sum yourself up in a few
thoughts game as a human being what
would you say uh
i'm imperfect uh i
you know
i care a lot about
things that are happening and i try to
find a way to express those
feelings or those thoughts
in a way
that makes it easy for others you know
and for me specifically it's through
comedy and so if i can make people laugh
then it makes me feel better not through
like oh if people laugh it's great like
it's like i
it gives me a sense that like okay cool
like
[ __ ] was hard it is hard for people
but
the
ability to like
get them to
decompress a second you know or like let
go and be like okay you know like yeah
it's tough but at least i you know was
able to let off some steam there and
have a laugh like i look at that i'm
like cool
yeah
and i think right now especially like
you look at i mean
through the pandemic and through this
crazy hyper-political
segmented society that we live in in our
country
you know globally
uh all of these issues that are
happening you know if there's any moment
in time when i can be like oh here's a
dumb thing that i came up with my head
made people laugh right and like as long
as there's a couple people laughing i'm
like okay you know i i helped some
people
uh to kind of deal with that because
honestly that's the only way that i'm
able to die like it
never i did not plan to go down this
route to do the pal yeah
it's just like i was like making videos
and then i was like well i i have
somewhat of a platform so i probably
should say something and then i was like
well the only way i know how to say it
is to do it through satire or parody or
some sort of sketch and then it you know
then now now every time i see like oh
that's so [ __ ] crazy oh man imagine
what that was like when they were trying
to you know like
steal the documents from the white house
to go to mar-a-lago like what was that
like or what what did they find in those
boxes like yes you know insane things
that you would never imagine in your
life to be like we're having this
conversation right now yeah and it's
every day it's every [ __ ] day it does
not stop you know i didn't stop
i i really i would i thought after the
election like i know he fought it in the
big line all that stuff i really thought
it would chill it would it would at
least like you know [ __ ] turn turn
the heat off the kettle and bring that
whistle down but my god it just only
ramped up even more because after
january 6 it was [ __ ] everything's on
fire and you know what the problem is
granted if he croaks tomorrow it should
be a great thing
if the ideology is still there right the
pla the the play out of his playbook is
there forever and all that look wait
till we get to the midterms whoever
loses on their side and i hope like how
we win you know vote blewer we're all
screwed but i got a feeling we're going
to get [ __ ] slaughtered i hope not i
hope not yeah but regardless the
republicans that do lose they're all
going to [ __ ] say it was it was
rigged it's all it's you know it's and
it's disgusting um
final question if you have one
what is the saying you live your life by
the same
um
don't
don't get too hard on yourself you know
i i like uh
and what i mean by that is like
time is tough
and i said before like what are you like
i'm you know i'm imperfect you know
nobody nobody is is perfect and we all
have our own flaws because that's we are
as humans
and
it's to understand like we all make
mistakes you know
and to in a certain extent you got to
look at and be like
you should be you know putting yourself
down every time you make a mistake right
there are obviously certain things
that'll be very bad or whatever that
happened in life but at the most part
like especially the little things
like this day and age like so many
whether it's somebody says something
online because you did say something
accidentally or whatever or
or at work or in your relationships or
whatever like those are things i'm like
the little things
just don't
don't let it get get you down and i
understand it's like [ __ ] i made a
mistake and i can you know i can own up
to it and be like sorry let's mend this
or let's fix this or whatever as opposed
to like [ __ ] i'm super stressed about
this now and i got this anxiety and i
got this pressure and i just feel like
it becomes unhealthy where it just like
builds on itself and you've got all
these other things happening in the
world and that just like compounds on on
your own personal stuff and it's like
just being okay with not let you know
just like not letting it bring you down
not like not
not uh
not getting stressed out over over
things that you know are sometimes out
of control right it's like i don't have
to say that i don't have a part in that
that's not me
so okay
for the viewers what are all your social
media platforms
yeah
uh so across social media it's uh
twitter tiktok instagram
um
is all at i am gabe sanchez so i am gabe
sanchez easy my name that's what it is
okay and give them the one for you yours
and tony's podcast yeah and so uh
the our podcast at tony michael's
podcast is tony at tony michael's pod so
that's just at tony michael's pod
okay
all right i'm gonna give you a close-up
with a few thoughts i'm gonna give you
back to mike to close out
uh like i said earlier everything guests
that i bring on
in some way shape or form they're moving
humanity forward you and tony are doing
that whether it's through humor because
even though even though those videos are
[ __ ] hilarious there's a message
there so i always say and tony got me
beating and cursing but i do curse a lot
too and i always say don't get caught up
in the in all the cursing all the time
listen to the message because there's
always a message there even in your tic
toc videos you may be mocking an
incident but it's a real life incident
so you may be adding humor to it because
it's so [ __ ] insane and
you know sometimes we got to do it
through humor to deal with the stupidity
of like a donald trump jr or whatever
but there's still a message there
because if you go and look
there's a real there's something real
that happened there when you when you
were doing your joe rogan stuff and
roasting his ass and rightfully so
because people you know they think he
gets a pass because he's joe rogan
nobody gets to pass you do evil [ __ ]
[ __ ] no matter if it's you me or whoever
or if
you oh you own if you support us then
you own us all the evil [ __ ] that we do
you don't get to pick and choose say
well i like them on monday but tuesday's
a jackass and wednesday i like them
again because that's what they try to do
with trump they always want to say well
yeah he i don't like what he says or the
way he talks to women or black people
but i like his policies no you own all
of it you own all of it
but you guys are moving humanity forward
you're doing it through your tick tock
videos you're doing through the tony
michael's pod um i'm glad again
congratulations again that you're on the
midas touch network because it's going
to amplify your guys voices into a
larger area which is good because we
need
people like you and tony doing what
you're doing because we got so many on
the [ __ ] right that every single
[ __ ] day it's insanity so i thank you
for that and thank you for moving manny
forward and coming on let me give you
back to mike close out any thoughts you
want
yeah i just want to say you know thank
you so much for for having me on uh this
has been a blast just you know i don't
get to talk with many people outside of
the my girlfriend and my dogs or tony
so
so the social interaction here is great
and i really appreciate it uh and yeah
just like you know give me the time to
say my thoughts you know on whether it's
random questions or things about
politics and i would say this for anyone
listening or watching
again i
never
expected i i was you know never thought
i would uh even
find myself in a position where i'd be
giving
social commentary or political
commentary through through a comedic
lens you know i thought maybe like a
sketch here and there but i never
thought it would be like every video i
made you know i thought again after the
election i'd be like great i'm going to
go into more evergreen content and then
the [ __ ] world blew up even more
after january 6.
so
you know
i think
it's important to remember for anyone
out there who's like oh what can i do
like what
what difference do i make or whatever
you know i was someone you know last
year who
i was small following i was building it
up uh you know and
and to know that anyone
you know regardless you are can make a
difference and you have a voice and you
have a message
and you'd be surprised how many people
will
uh will find that message comforting
right in whatever the formatter or or
medium it is
um there's a group out there whatever it
is that will will welcome you in and i
and i think that that's probably been
one of the more
um nice and grateful things and and
somewhat surprising you know when i
started again i had no idea what i was
doing and i didn't think anyone was
really gonna listen and then
now i've got different platforms where
people are like oh
you know tagging me and stuff and
telling me oh i should look into this
and whatever you know and so it's it's
great to see and just to know that like
at the end of the day
just speaking up you know even it's a
tweet or a video whatever it is like it
can make a difference and it can inspire
someone or it can
help others understand some topic that
might be
you know oh it's political it's too
complicated no at the core of it there
is something basic and how it you know
it comes down to it
i know i agree with you i piggyback over
what you just said i tell people that
all the time i don't care if you have 10
followers or 10 million followers your
voices matter because
one voice
with another voice with another voice
they become single voices into multiple
voices into a movement and that's really
how simple it is people think it's like
so complicated but it's really not and
as as you well know there's more of us
than them right unfortunately
a lot of people don't use their
platforms to speak out which i mean not
everybody's made to speak out i'm not
going to condemn you i i understand not
everybody is made to do it but if you're
made to do it do it because
they're eating up the greens and the
bobarts they're eating up the news
cycles and the clips and this and the
thing that they're constantly doing and
you notice very well
every time they say something [ __ ]
stupid they go and raise money off of it
and they're raising a lot of money
because their constituents who put them
in power are just as [ __ ] up as they
are and i don't give no passes if you
vote anybody that goes and votes for
bobart again or green for example or a
cruise you're just as [ __ ] evil as
them and if you want to talk about
family i'll
just one thought because i can't stand
cruz
this is the man and you notice it that
trump said his wife was ugly and his
father helped kill kennedy and he did
nothing to basically he said two little
words and then he grovels at the [ __ ]
of trump
daily yeah i mean you're not even you're
not even remotely a man you left you
went to cancun and left your dog
snowflake at the house and snowflake
thinks you're a [ __ ] right and
blamed it on your daughters you're like
i was just being a good father exactly
like yeah did they do they need you to
take him down or could your wife have
taken a date and you want and you want
to know something and say so to that
point if cruz would have said the power
is out i'm sending you honey and the
kids to get out of here but i gotta stay
for my constituents to do stuff i would
have never said a word people would have
complained and said no they should have
stayed no it's his family they're not in
politics right they can go but you don't
take your ass down and the only reason
he said something you know it is because
his [ __ ] ass got caught if he would
have got caught he would have said a
[ __ ] word and and since then he
hasn't shut the [ __ ] up
yeah so on that note on the shut the
[ __ ] up and your your catch line is what
[ __ ] him
uh yeah [ __ ] him yeah yeah tony's i love
when he put the head on [ __ ] him and i
like the guy that does the voice over
for the show oh yeah and [ __ ] him he's
got that perfect like tv voice i was
talking to tony the other night about
that so
on that note hey again i really do
appreciate you coming on let's stay in
touch uh if you need something tweeted
out or whatever tag me i'll push it out
i tell you tony and i always support
each other you're in the mix too so we
got to work together brother
thank you so much all right take care
all right folks that's another episode
of the bad brad burke with show on the
ringside report web tv channel gabe
sanchez another gentleman out there
who's moving humanity forward him and
his co-host
tony michaels of the tony michaels pod
they do some great stuff hilarious check
out his tick tock videos you're gonna
you're gonna freaking
trust me you're gonna laugh your ass off
but there's also a message there don't
forget that and even though tony and i
curse a lot never forget that we have a
message so all that cursing is just us
animated because we feel so strongly
about the things that we're talking
about all right make sure you subscribe
to the channel again follow me on
twitter at bad brad rsr again at
badbread rsr and finally check out my
great writing team at ringsidereport.com
all right folks
that's another one in the can forget
about it
and remember
every act of kindness is a little love
we leave behind
bad bread out thank you for watching the
bad brad birkwood show please follow
subscribe leave comments forget about it
and move humanity forward
[Music]